[Music]
and let's talk about it News and it's
submitted by the patreon squad yeah
thank you but Rihanna's Bellator's
Sesame Street addresses the opioid
crisis as a Muppets mother battles
addiction progress they are they are and
they're coming HBO max I think you know
snuffleupagus a heroin addict what I
don't know
now he's a STONER is very sleepy all the
time oh yeah he's [ __ ] high Sun this
eyes
it's we dude are you sure cuz he's never
like that he just took like yeah and
he's still alive and he's not skinny
this is the first time they address a
big fiction but they've done stuff like
mystic character I like Julie oh right
yeah they've done this stuff does your
sound watch mm-hmm yeah sometimes and
but it's very telling that it the
problem so bad that they have to have
his Sesame Street a girl in it so they
created this new Muppet name is Carly
what does it look like like this she's
super cute wait that looks like the
other one Oh which other one like Oscar
Elmer no there's another one that has
down syndrom right yeah yeah no she's
autistic and it's their names Julia
oh yeah thought Cystic wonders autistic
what their autistic one yeah I think so
yeah there might be a dance on your
muppet though I thought so the pink one
with a the yellow the yellow I don't
know if I'm supposed to be down soon or
Muppet or a muppet with Down syndrome
who cares why remember oh yeah you gotta
be character by this is the Muppet with
on queer uh that's Julia right oh yeah
the other one do you this I almost like
a Kermit but does he watch you talk of
an Ernie that's tree he is more of a
Ernie did he does he watch Sesame Street
uh not too much he's really into Mickey
Mouse right
oh but we played it a lot like during
his first year and he would like watch
it for like three seconds and go do
something like I didn't like when other
kids were on the show cuz I would get
jealous same Wow same I'm like what do I
gotta do yeah exactly I'm like Huckle
they're special
yep like they got picked and it is
booked special day I'm like I probably
look way more tv-friendly than this kid
so Carly was first introduced as a
foster home foster care child like
living a foster kid
Thank You foster kid and so initially it
was just seen as like Oh Carly's mom has
to be away so now she has to live and
this home with Fornell parents and
that's how she was initially introduced
but then now they're Carly's mom is back
and they're talking about how Carly's
mom needs to go to daily meetings and
with other parents who have same kind of
grown-up problems mmm so I'm gonna play
it's pretty cool that's really cool
normalizing it yeah I think it's really
quite I've always hated on like my
parents or other adults tried to like
sweep it under the rug so much mother
[ __ ] like I think I'm smart I might
not understand the whole thing but I
know something's not right in your lie
yeah kids are smart the parents were
just stupid I'm gonna play video clip
and so this girl here her parents
struggled with addiction and now they've
been clean for eight years and she's
she's at Carly's friend in the shishi
acting or did she really have a mob that
was addicted you will see her mother you
know my mom was having a hard time with
addiction and I felt like my family was
the only one going through it but now
I've met so many other kids like a silly
motivation oh I want him up at hook
what an egg yeah what if I feel like
they need alcohol another kind of okay
that can make a person extreme Sesame
Workshop providing these resources to
children and families who are
experiencing addiction within the
household is amazing and it makes me
feel grateful to know that others are
acknowledging that there is an issue
[Music]
that's really cool so what was her mom's
choice a drug no crap tell us but why
July 2008 years dude okay so she pumped
up maybe you could be clean now okay
she's been clean for eight I just never
seen a healthy looking crackhead is what
I'm saying
well we're saying it's been eight years
I know oh that's like two high schools
or a high school into college I know so
what's happening I just thought she'd
just got off of it so this is this
series here they will be showing it
online and it's part of like Sesame
Workshop which is like something that
you can you can access online and so
they're just saying that addiction is
seen as a grown-up issue but it impacts
children in ways that often aren't
visible take a look at our new resources
that help the whole family cope and
build hope for the future I thought they
were gonna have an intervention with
Cookie Monster and like just do it with
other you know they made him eat
vegetables not cookies anymore because
of diabetes you know no he's still
cookie monster he's just not allowed to
eat cookies cookies every once in a
while you balance you know in moderation
or their protein cookies are free he'll
grab the cookies just like flies all
over the place you know loading that was
my favorite but you know what you need
to be addicted to just kidding news so
subscribe so you could keep up with all
the videos right it's a healthy
addiction when we learned about drunk
driving in school and they were like you
know we're you took the DARE program and
stuff well my dad will put beer in a
McDonald's cup of tripe and I'm like dad
you're drinking and driving and he's
like no I'm not I'm driving and drinking
oh [ __ ] okay that's true because I
remember like so you doesn't do that
anymore yeah you're grown up now it's
not that fine there's limitations also
let me drink some oh I'd be like dad I'm
thirsty okay I guess I liked it when I
was a good wine you weren't like you Oh
gross I think as I thought him enjoy it
so much it made me want to enjoy it like
I even though was nasty
yeah like when I was a kid I always
wanted to enjoy like grown-up things so
I remember like forcing myself to like
it onions like to me onions were a
grown-up thing and olives too oh yeah
mustard like all these things were like
grown-up it's like literally McDonald's
like in the play area when you don't
grow up white mustard is a grown-up weed
there's no reason why we need mustard in
any dish in our [ __ ] Mexican cuisine
it's pretty gross as a kid though yes
I'm like I hated it but I pretend like
damn grown-up I like it I tried to drink
my dad's black coffee but that did not
work because you would drink it every
morning it's not like I'm gonna try some
of this stuff it's not good well now I
drink black coffee but no it's true to
you or something this is cool though
because you know what I feel like that
they're very right in saying that it's a
very grown-up
issue that they try and hide from kids
and the more kids can embrace it and
learn to talk about it the better chance
they have at not being bucked out from
it like that but then they're also
saying like you know if a parent out
there is struggling with addiction and
they they actually sit down and watch
Sesame Street and this first one second
and they get to see something like this
and me
it might get to them like oh should I
need to get clean for my kids like they
see this they're exposed to it - yeah
they watch it in there like I'm so
stressed out I gotta go smoke some
[ __ ] crack now or they can react that
way too but yeah so they're saying like
they've tackled a lot of things like you
were mentioning before - like they've
talked about like military families they
like mental health issues they expose a
lot of cultural [ __ ] - yeah like they
did like Chinese line dancing and stuff
it was really cool I'm like oh that's
tight yeah there's actually through
Sesame Street that I learned about the
lycée like the Chinese the red envelopes
oh what's that got some knowledge oh I
think during Chinese New Year's family
members all with money yeah yeah I
didn't until you're married and then you
have to give this it's your turn yeah so
I give my younger cousins because we're
not married so now I'm considered their
elder so I give them rather married
married even though we're part of the
same generation we're cousins now I'm
like motive so now it's not like it's
married people that give it to younger
people mm-hmm what if you're a 40 year
old single man but in the Chinese family
probably disowned by that I do that just
occasion my boyfriend started buying for
his cousin's his little cousins Bitcoin
because they were like why don't we
[ __ ] need Bitcoin he's like exactly
keep it in your [ __ ] email and don't
look at it for 20 years and by the time
you're in college you're gonna be
thanking me kissing my pose [ __ ] he
doesn't talk to them like that
I thought that was an interesting that's
true twenty years but like how phase
would you be if you're a little kid and
someone hands you like a certificate
[ __ ] am I supposed to do with that
I want a bubble gum it's like the art
type are savings bonds like back in the
day like you get used to give it when
the kids are born and then like when
they're 18 they can cash it or whatever
and it's worth more I've heard of it oh
I used to see mine and I knew it was
mine like I knew it belonged to me but
my mom's like you can't cash it till
you're 18 and I would get so mad because
I'm like it's mine though it felt
special yeah we did
[ __ ] that's why that I'm like I heard of
that there's incentives to not get
arrested get a DUI or get pregnant when
you grow up in the south your parents
started saving Shaunie for you and if
you can make it through high school
without getting all three then they give
it to you that's a good idea
oh I got one of those like do you I know
I was a kid my mom had like a little
savings account being for me and
whenever I got all the red envelopes we
would go to the bank deposit it and then
like so I have my own little account
book and it'd be like oh you have like
$200 $200 and as I got older like when I
was like I don't know like 12 it was
like 3,800 the money was mine but just
she would like whenever I was gonna
spend money she would always let me know
like do you want to spend it or do you
want to put into this thing and you can
kind of turn it into a game and you can
add more to it
they should be gamifying finances for
kids cuz we don't learn [ __ ] dick about
[ __ ] in high school about taxes and [ __ ]
that's true but do we learn [ __ ] about
dick we do yeah the sex ed class I know
dick and not enough about my did you
know they don't teach sex ed in every
state that's [ __ ] yeah they teach
abstinence and a lot of state I didn't
know that so what is that they just say
like though like the only safe sex is no
sex and they don't teach anything of
course just one [ __ ] they don't have a
course it's just like we don't know
nobody talks about it there's like Red
Ribbon Week like like accidents a week
for the school so no it's abstinence
forever no I mean like but since there's
no course because there's no Red Ribbon
Week course or like you know yeah that's
how they do it I don't know I didn't
live there but yeah yeah we never think
maybe it's just the mindset of like the
center you start [ __ ] the sooner you
maybe you don't know about it then they
won't do it
[Music]
you
[Music]
you